[Norvig] So here I have the 2 calls to max.
And when I hit Run, I see the answers are 5 and -5.
So the first call to max, what's the maximum of 3, 4, 5, and 0?
That's 5. That's the highest number.
The second call to max I'm using the keyword argument which says
give me the maximum according to this function,
so give me the maximum of these numbers
according to the absolute value of those numbers.
And the largest absolute value is -5 has the absolute value of 5, so that's the highest,
and so that gives me the highest value.
And so here we see the result -5 is the actual value
which has the highest according to the absolute function, and so it tells me -5 is the best.